"The Batman" was filled with moments of dramatic
character revelations and brutal action,
but one scene in particular that dealt with
Selina Kyle's past stands out. It's time to
talk about that Catwoman scene in "The Batman."
While the movie is called "The Batman," Selina
Kyle, also known as Catwoman, plays a vital role
in the story. Bruce Wayne first runs into her
in the Iceberg Lounge, as she works for Oswald
Cobblepot as a server. Batman notices Selina's
reaction to seeing pictures of a mystery woman
exiting the club with Mayor Don Mitchell Jr.
Batman follows Selina and discovers that the woman
is actually Selina's roommate. But the first time
they truly meet is when Selina breaks into the
mayor's house to retrieve her roommate's passport,
and from that point on, they are entangled.
As the story unravels, more of Selina's backstory
and motivations are revealed. This includes
a crucial connection with Carmine Falcone,
the mob boss who works closely with
Cobblepot and frequents the Iceberg Lounge.
When the truth of Falcone's crimes
comes to light thanks to the Riddler,
both Selina and Bruce decide to go after Falcone.
"Come on, Vengeance. Let's get into some trouble."
Unfortunately, Selina is a bit more serious about
how she wants to punish him, and Bruce doesn't
agree. But there's nothing stopping Selina
from going after what she wants. This leads
to a key scene in the last third of the film that
features major action and devastating revelations.
Once Selina learns that Falcone is
behind the death of her roommate,
she decides to kill him. Heading to his club, she
dresses up and asks to talk to him in private,
hiding a gun in her bag. But Selina is
interrupted right as she reaches for
the weapon. Batman is unleashing
his wrath in the very next room.
Bruce wants to stop Selina from committing murder,
but he also has his own business with Falcone.
By this point, Alfred has confirmed that
all signs point to Falcone ordering the
murder of his parents years earlier. But
Bruce is forced to face off against guards,
and Selina gets the chance to confront Falcone.
She plans on getting revenge for her roommate's
brutal death. She also wants answers about the
revelation that she's Falcone's daughter, which
apparently he doesn't know until this moment.
It's equally possible that he simply doesn't care.
Feeling like her father abandoned her years
earlier and knowing all of the horrors Falcone has
committed, Selina pulls the trigger…and misses.
This leads father and daughter to battle head-on,
out in the open. While Selina is
skilled, Falcone's ruthlessness
allows him to gain the upper hand.
During the confrontation at the
club between Falcone and Selina, she plays
the audio that reveals his direct role in
her roommate's death. She was an innocent
woman who just happened to hear too much.
Falcone strangles her, a detail that, only
minutes later, becomes even more important.
Selina also reminds Falcone of her mother,
Maria Kyle, and her death. Earlier in "The
Batman," Selina tells Bruce that her mother
was murdered when she was very young,
likely by one of the clients at the club. While
Falcone first seems to feel some semblance of
emotional connection to Selina's mother's
name, another horrific truth comes out as
Falcone attacks his daughter. He manages to knock
her to the ground and push down on her neck,
beginning to strangle her. It's at that point that
Falcone reveals that he killed Maria the same way.
If Selina hadn't managed to get away soon after,
she would have met the same fate as her mother.
And though audiences might root for Selina
to take down Falcone for good, she decides
that justice will be better served if he lives to
suffer the consequences of his villainy. To Bruce,
it means that Selina won't have to hold onto the
trauma that comes from taking someone's life.
In the end, while it's not by her own hand,
Selina does see her father die that night. With
the face-off with Falcone behind her, Selina
decides to leave Gotham City and start over
somewhere else, something Bruce probably should
do as well, though we all know he never will.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.